it was so much fun man working with
Jackie Chan man this guy he's amazing
man I definitely uh prepared myself
because I knew it was Jackie Chan I
didn't want to you know let him down I
worked out lift weights ran you know the
first one uh made sure I was in tip top
shape so whenever he was like come on
you know and I was ready
but he made it so easy man with the
martial arts and all you know stuff he
was just swinging me around basically
just following him man go this way kick
this way look this way made it look like
I knew what I was doing so it was good
he was doing things his way uh
differently you know and breaking the
rules a lot of the scenes was just off
the script I mean the Improv Jackie
followed me a lot but he was so good the
chemistry was so great man he knew when
I went off on something he was right
there with reaction and all that stuff
and with the action you know he's the
man that with that so I just like what
we're gonna do what you want me to do